j'ai examiné depuis deux semaines
l'évolution du deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle au travers de
la lettre que j'ai adressée aux deux
candidats de leurs réponses des
interventions publiques et du débat
d'hier soir je les fais au nom d'un
courant politique qui a été soutenue au
premier tour par plus de 3 millions de
français au sein de ce courant politique
il ait des sensibilités diverses plus à
droite plus à gauche trait au centre et
c'est naturel c'est naturel parce que le
courant central du pays
quand il est soumis au choix impitoyable
de la bipolarisation est forcément
divers
cette diversité j'y tiens elle s'est
exprimée tout au long de la journée dans
des réunions qui ont été amicale
passionnante et respectueuse
cette diversité elle est notre nature
propre c'est pourquoi je ne donnerai pas
de consignes générales de vote chacun de
mes amis chacun de mes électeurs
s'exprimera en conscience je sais qu'il
y aura des expressions différentes et je
les respecterai
je veux donc vous dire ici mon
engagement et mon jugement personnel
nicolas sarkozy après un bon score de
premier tour s'est livré à une course
poursuite à l'extrême droite dans
laquelle nous ne retrouvons pas nos
valeurs dans laquelle ce que nous
croyons de plus profond et de plus
précieux a été bousculé et nier dans son
principe
l'obsession de l'immigration dans un
pays comme la france au point de
présenter dans son clip de campagne
un panneau douanes écrit en français et
en arabe qui ne voient à quel
affrontements hacker l'affrontement
entre français
cela mènera l'obsession des frontières à
rétablir comme si elle avait totalement
disparu et que nous y avions perdu notre
âme qui ne voient que cela mène à la
négation du projet européen auquel le
centre et la droite autant que la gauche
modérée française on donnait des
décennies d'action et de conviction et
quant à l'idée que l'école
ce devrait être l'apprentissage des
frontières qui ne voit que c'est une
déviation même est une négation de
l'idée d'école qui est fait au contraire
pour que s'effacent les frontières entre
les esprits entre les consciences entre
les époques la ligne k ainsi choisi
nicolas sarkozy entre les deux tours et
violente
elle entre en contradiction avec les
valeurs qui sont les nôtres pas
seulement les miennes pas seulement
celle du courant politique que je
représente
mais aussi les valeurs du gaullisme
autant que celle de la droite
républicaine et sociale
comment en est on arrivé là ce sera
l'histoire de cette élection de cette
rupture au sein du peuple français
rupture qui vient de loin qui se prépare
depuis longtemps rupture économique
sociale et morale
je ne veux pas voter blanc cela serait
de l'indécision et dans ces
circonstances
l'indécision est impossible reste le
vote pour françois hollande c'est le
choix que je fais il s'est prononcé de
manière claire celle au club
françois hollande s'est prononcé de
manière claire sur la moralisation de la
vie publique dans notre pays
il aura fort à faire j'ai dit ce que je
pensais de son programme économique
je ne partage pas ce programme je pense
au contraire qu'il est inadaptée à la
situation du pays est encore plus encore
plus à la crise qui vient que j'ai
annoncée et que je crois certaines mais
je pense que devant cette crise
inéluctable il n'y aura pour la nation
qu'une attitude possible une unité
nationale qui réunira des femmes et des
hommes venus d'horizons différents pour
que le pays puisse se ressaisir et même
se reconstruire
cette unité nationale elle ne se
réalisera jamais si chacun reste dans la
logique des camps anciens une opposition
en embuscade contre une majorité et dont
le seul but est qu'elle se casse la
figure
la situation de notre pays encore
davantage la situation que notre pays va
connaître est trop grave pour cela je ne
suis pas et je ne deviendrai pas un
homme de gauche je suis un homme du
centre et j'entends le rester et je suis
certain que le jour venu il faudra aussi
qu'une partie de la droite républicaine
soit associée à ce qu'il va falloir
faire pour que la france s'en sorte
par ce choix je rend possible pour la
première fois depuis longtemps cette
union nationale la vraie mobilisation
des français au service de la france
il appartiendra à françois hollande s'il
est élu de réfléchir à la situation et
de prendre en compte cette nécessité
pour le pays s'il en reste à la gauche
classique et au programme qui est le
sien aujourd'hui
je serai un opposant dans une opposition
vigilante constructive mais vigilante
et il faudra une opposition déterminée
quand il s'agira d'empêcher les erreurs
annoncé il est des moments dans
l'histoire où l'engagement devient vital
je crois que le moment est venu de
franchir des pas décisifs
nous devons tous nous allons devoir tous
où que nous soyons nous dépasser et nous
rassembler pour que la france se
reconstruise je vous remercie